Hi, I'm Bonnie Greer.
I'm a playwright, novelist, commentator...
...and I was born on the south side of Chicago.
I've lived here since 1986 and I'm Deputy Chair of the British Museum.
This is See Britain Through My Eyes.
The British Museum is the ultimate Enlightenment institution.
We hold a collection of seven million - plus objects...
...and we hold them for all of the world, free to all of the world.
So you walk through this dark aperture,...
...this kind of classical Greek temple, the 18th century idea of the Enlightenment.
It's dark and tiny.
And suddenly the museum opens up, full of light, full of movement...
...where you see people of all colors and nations.
This is like a Tower of Babel in a sense.
There's so many languages represented here.
This museum embodies the notion that we better learn about our own culture in relation to other cultures.
And so the colonial era actually turned London into what it still is today: a hub city.
So that the notion of globalization, in its good sense,...
...actually you could say began at this place...
...where all the peoples of the world have left behind their story.
And so it is right that this collection in this museum sits in the middle of that hub.